i was thinking about this the the rules
on wheel of fortune are very specific
there's been a lot of controversy like
if you've got to say it just the right
way
when you answer or they take away the
points a few weeks ago wheel of fortune
viewers were up in arms a contestant
appeared to solve a puzzle correctly but
pat sajak said he got it wrong
i like to solve pat say everything don't
add anything go ahead
soul flounder cod and catfish
yeah i'm sorry that's not right and
danielle
it's your turn soul cod catfish
flounder yeah that's it
[Music]
that's what you said and i know it's
always confusing
and david did that thing that's so easy
to do you added the ad anyway
the main thing is danielle has 3 200 and
a wild card
they're right you got to have a rule
because
otherwise there's chaos on these shows
pat warned him though he said he did
solve the puzzle
and don't add anything you don't think
pat
like is trying like he says that rule
very quickly
like like he wants them to get it wrong
jd he says
don't add any extra words now
okay if he said it like that uh maybe
but
no he goes please don't edit anything he
says it very quickly
well i mean what's he going to do he's
going to sit there and train them i mean
there's a specific type of puzzle that
you got to try to
solve wait a second you're telling me
that you believe
that person should have won even though
they added an and
i think we all know what's we all know
what the deal is it's
it's very finicky no we don't you know
why i think
you're upset about the whole wheel of
fortune thing seriously
your speech is so inexact like you know
how you add whatever to everything like
you would be like
uh flounder cod uh catfish
or whatever yeah and then and then
they'll be like
your nightmare is being exact that's
very true
i do require a lot of interpretation
with uh what i say sometimes
you add too much stuff but exactly
whatever
[Music]
i'm sorry jd you don't win the million
dollars ah whatever
[Music]
jd please don't add anything
yeah like that pat sajak has jd on uh
wheel of fortune goes listen jd
i know something's wrong with you i
don't know you haven't been diagnosed
but
don't add any extra words especially
whatever
and then you know
jd what do you do for a living i'm an
extra word activist
i don't give a [ __ ] what you say i'm
putting in extra words well you won't
win
i don't care jd you're a big spelling
bee guy because jd in the fourth grade
spelling bee sixth grade he's a true
spelling bee and jd is very upset at the
changes they made to the national
spelling bee rules so you're a guy who
believes in rules what was the big rule
they made
like it's not john you said it was uh
would you say it was uh
yeah but it's funnier when you say it
yeah we don't want to interrupt you
don't get john to explain it you explain
it my dream is to say to you jd
explain the new spelling bee rules and
then just sit back and listen go ahead
start again basically the contestants
are gonna
get a word and they have to guess what
it means and it's not
it's not a goddamn word it's not an
english
it's not a vocabulary be it's a spelling
bee you gotta know how to spell the word
not know what it means so give me an
example in other words
let's say the word is
anti-disestablishmentarianism
or whatever is that where it is i don't
know what that word means but so they
would say okay
uh uh howard anti this disestablished
uh whatever that word was uh
anti-dis-establishmentarianism go ahead
all right ask me the question
establishmentarianism does it mean
uh establishing something does it mean a
doesn't mean establishing something oh
so you guys are upset
john you're upset too that the they're
asking them what the words mean as yeah
just spelling them i can't put it as
eloquently as jd just did but yeah
i mean you're there to spell why are
they adding that
because they have too many kids winning
they had like a ten
person person in person yeah i mean how
can you have eight winners on a spelling
bee that's ridiculous
they ran out of words they ran out of
words on the list
they can't get somebody in a back room
get no more words
jd's highlight of his life was that
fourth grade spelling bee
where he won sixth grade he's still got
the trophy
it's on some shitty bookcases
what's it saying jd i can't read it uh
fairborn city schools champion champions
black lane
1991 92.
[Music]
i was 11 and 12 years old [ __ ] all
downhill from there
oh i'm here but yeah that's true depends
on the day i guess
it's not so great being here sometimes